okay
welcome to another live stream about
incremental language development for
language looks like a simple agenda
today
those are usually deceptive all right
let's start off with echo evaluation
okay so
is this the prototype it is not the
prototype build let me start the
prototype build
um a little background noise by the way
that might be how to say um
there's some kind of problem with
startup by the way can somebody report
that i mean there's some kind of problem
with startup speeds i don't know what's
happening here
yeah and there's something you know look
at that weird state that's in
um
okay let's just copy over the cells
here
all right echo evaluation
okay so this is inna
boy we're looking at this idea of having
multiple elements
to represent nesting
so this is an echo within an echo
basically
so if i i mean if i were to write a
fibonacci
oops that's not what i really wanted but
let me just fill in there
okay so here i would say echo evaluation
of this
[Music]
right
yep okay so now i say
fair before
okay let's try
um
oh my god what the hell is going on here
well at least i can see fibonacci
numbers coming out with with the
red you know with the orange thingies
right
i think you are missing uh memorization
here
perhaps but i wasn't intending to
memorize i was i'm happy
recursing i'm trying to understand what
on earth i'm seeing here
this is like tree nesting
for the echo evaluations
so
fundamentally you know this is a
bracketed thing
it's there to there right
everything is bracketed that that guy
goes with the sky here
i mean
it is interesting that we have cell
brackets here
and one slightly crazy idea would be to
use the cell bracket structure
to nest these things is that obviously
totally bonkers
you mean the same and the right or are
the new brackets on the left somehow
i was thinking the same on the right
just literally have the cells nest
somehow
sander on our live stream is saying
should the echoes be inside out or
outside
in
yeah correct yeah go ahead if you go
down there is a terminal example in
which
the gilamets go to the right
what no the guillemins go to the left
here and to the right on
output oh sorry sorry i'm just
interpreting
they're they're growing to the right as
you nest deeper
oh i sure should've said whereas in a
notebook they go to the left
well we don't have a lot of choice in
the terminal do we
now the alternative here
for the one below let's see
oh that's an echo matched with
oh god that's another problem you know
what we cannot have the same color for
echo and for echo
evaluate we've got to have different
colors otherwise this case is going to
get
crazy ambiguous right
if you have an echo you don't know if
the echo closed necro evaluation
pair whether it's its own separate echo
so billy we need another color for this
okay um
and i feel like maybe we should just
make
both of these matched in color
could we can we try could you mark
something like this with with um
uh what's an appropriate color for what
is our evaluation color
i'll try maybe you can do
is go ahead i guess it's visually
lighter than an input
it's it's not this you know it's the
same color but it's visually
oh i switched a second you're suggesting
something like this something like the
and out labels
that's a good idea
now it's a good that's a good basis for
for thinking about this
um yeah why not go ahead
let's last week we were thinking that
the gilamets were very similar to the
left and to the right and that's why we
wanted to have different colors
well we can have slightly different
colors
and it raises the question of whether we
i mean i have to say one of the things
that's been a long-term
issue of mine okay it's a weird weird
point but
the numbers in here are very hard to
read
now i don't think we want to further
emphasize them but i don't know if
there's a way to make them more readable
maybe give them extra space or something
but you know
i'm like when i'm when i'm using
you know i use this ridiculously high
resolution screen
um usually you know i often have to
peer forward to see these these um
these numbers on the screen which i
don't have to do for any other thing
that's that's
um that's in the notebook
so i mean that's the thing billy that's
the thing for you probably
um uh you know
is there a way to improve readability
without
improving emphasis of those numbers
and to me the main thing is what you
really want to read is the number you
you know the in-out you can kind of see
it's in
or out and it might be you know maybe
it's a curling issue with the number
you get what i'm saying yeah that's yeah
that might it might be helpful to space
it out a little bit
let's do some experiments on that okay
okay with respect to these
um okay how crazy is my cell bracket
idea
it's pretty crazy actually it wouldn't
even work because
yeah it wouldn't even work now what
about the possibility
is there any way that clicking on these
could do anything
there's any way if this isn't totally
bonkers that we could put in cell tags
so that that thing could find its its
pair
so to speak
and some number following also the idea
of in out
with some numbers all right hidden a
number
hidden number i mean that would be very
useful to me if i could click this
and it will find you know it will it
will highlight or jump to or something
um actually brian on a live stream it's
just suggesting billy
just a thin space on either side of the
number in the in out that might be a
really good
simple solution yeah
okay yeah just as a character
yeah i also have a tool tip
oh that's a good point that
um uh that is a good point that this
thing could have a tool tip with it that
is a really good idea
a tool tip with a thing just bigger
or something i think bret suggested that
last time i guess
it would be like show the output itself
on tooltip wait a minute so which output
you mean of one of these out labels but
you can see the output it's right there
look the real thing we want honestly
what we really want is click to copy
that's what we really want because
that's what you want to do is you want
to use out three
right you want to click to copy and it
comes out as percent three
and in our percent modernization scheme
there'll be a more elaborate thing to
happen there but that's the immediate
thing and that could go to the user
assistance meeting
okay i'm suggesting click to copy there
yeah so i meant sorry i meant for the
echo
evaluation like if you moused over the
input expression then it could maybe
show the output expression in a tooltip
oh i see i don't know
well let's be clear the output
expression
could show the input expression but
absent time travel
it might not be possible to do the other
thing right
okay but even even the you know
okay so look all right we've got four
different things going on here
okay billy is dealing with the idea of
thin space here
um somebody is consulting with path
about the possibility of making this
structure copy who's doing that
i can sell that first okay
okay down here
[Music]
um
okay come up several suggestions here so
sander is suggesting and he's making a
reasonable point
that i can blow this up let me do 10.
actually it's not as stupid as it might
be but it is stupid at some level
because you can't really tell which
how big these are so sandra is
suggesting that above
level one that it's actually just a
little number there
um
and the number is cumulative it's not
the number of
parentheses say all right so
if we you still
mean so if we end evaluation 2
with an open evaluation 2 again will be
evolution 3.
that's going to get weird where does it
start counting
at the top of al at the at the at the
and what happens in the beginning of
each followers
beginning of each cell
so that's in the main evaluator
i think that's going to get weird i mean
we've already got something like this
with dialog
input
this case is weird
i sent a link to echo in
documentation which if you
there's just sort of like a point of
reference make it sort of mobile
width and narrow it um
you could sort of see the ins and outs
next to
the echoes i don't know if this is a
good example or not
but why is this different then from echo
if i did this with ordinary echo it
would look different
then are you saying if i did
echo instead of echo evaluation it would
do something so if i if i merge in here
if i say something like i mean let me
even make it even more confusing let me
echo that
that first piece there let me just do
the sixth case here
oh boy i don't know what the heck is
going on here
okay so there's echoes mixed in with
echo evaluations
okay so first of all let's talk about
technology that's possible
okay so first point is can we
highlight the matching one i believe
that we can
by putting a tag in here and by putting
code
that will essentially search down in the
notebook
to find the corresponding tag the tag is
is to uui
you know um
if the um tag is you id then you can do
that
somebody is complaining the font is too
small to read the text
somebody should figure out how to adjust
their
their view of this because this is this
is already expanded 150 percent
um
okay it's a question about interfacing
with dotnet
absolutely there's a whole net link this
is not subject to this meeting at all
but somebody can point you to that
a very elaborate system for doing that
[Music]
for using wolfram language from.net
um
somebody is suggesting an accessibility
zoom thing
for using 6k displays and i'm simply
going to send that to my systems person
because
i don't know i'm not dealing with that
right now
um
okay uh okay
okay let's come back to this um
okay look what are the suggestions on
the table
we've got okay so first of all if i
click this we should be able to
even into the future we should be able
to
find its pair make sense
yep okay
second point is here because
we're dealing with the past we could
burn in
here the knowledge of its of its paired
input
see what i'm saying
sandra's pointing out we need to yeah
look this this confusion within
with with ordinary echo is hopeless
right so we're going to assume that the
colors here
are based on the and out colors and so
now the question that we have on
before us is basically how do we do
this pairing you know what is the least
obscure way
to do the pairing of in-out labels
i mean of of echo in echo out
echo here okay
i would say that for small numbers of of
nesting levels
that this you know whatever it is
different you know
military ranks or whatever these things
are isn't bad
um the problem is when you get very deep
it's going to be hopeless
make sense so the question is when it
gets deep do we do we want a method
option or something
that allows us to um
uh you know to control
kind of um what happens here or how do
we want to do it
i think i would use a number when we go
more than three say
we just put a little number in front or
before okay what is that number gonna
look like
you mean in front of these things so we
go three deep
which means and so i don't understand
because right now
we're mixing some echoes in here right
so these echoes
are lined up the echo marks are lined up
with the right hand edge there
right these are out denting here and
obviously if they out dent too far
they have to indent this this content
so maybe what we do is we out dent until
what do we do two levels three levels i
don't know and then we go to numbers
i mean there's a there's an excuse to go
to numbers which is when you would have
to
indent the content if you're going to
have that many
you know uh whatever they are you know
stripes so for example we could use
three
and then four is gillimet a little for
dilemma
yes sounded certain that's called
gourmets i know they're called
columnists but i don't know what the
relationship is to
is that term i'm not even gonna i'm not
even gonna ask
well i am gonna ask because i'm curious
um
the single one of those is carrot i
don't know
what's your point that we use a single
one rather than a pair
uh maybe uh that is not a useful thing
m-e-t yeah
makes sense
no
well that's a word we're missing um
okay
okay so what what are you suggesting
here
i mean you're suggesting that we have
forward-pointing
things like this which have a sandwich
of a number in between
do large outputs do something like that
also
where's the ellipsis on either side am i
thinking of
yeah that's the ellipsis for for a large
output
that that's a little different
you know sandra is suggesting something
which looks like
n gula magulomei i'm not a big fan of
the paren
n thing because i think we we don't
really have that motif of a parenthesis
meaning something like that
well although it does look doesn't look
bad i mean so the question is are we
doing that
are we doing something like this
i think a stylized thing like this if
the design could work is pretty
reasonable
billy your comments
yeah if
i like having the number there initially
if we could
do that no we don't want to do that if
it's just a single echo evaluate
okay so look look question is
does it go a single one is this
a double one is this a triple one
is this
does that make sense to people
yep all right billy and can you while
this meeting is going on can you try and
make a design for these
okay and let's take a look at them okay
i would recommend i mean something based
on this
you know color value but i don't know
whether it's lightened or what
and then we're going to make sure have
to make sure that it plays nice with
echo itself
okay and then and then in terms of you
know it's a luxury item
to figure out how to get something okay
the mouse over
of the input seems doable here
and we should look at that okay i think
that will be an ian thing right to
actually look at the implementation of
that
yep in terms of the back end time idea
of jumping to the
you know you know in terms of the the
jumping forwards in time
let's investigate that i think that
requires some input from somebody in the
front end team
okay sounds good
okay why did the label get quotes around
it
can you do that in the prototype build
oh yes yes thank you
that's the answer sorry about that
um okay
so a question here would be uh
right so these labels would then go to
the teal color
brian is saying should the echo
indicates be similar to the in-out
symbology
i sort of think they are but but maybe
see because remember it's they're going
to nest they're going to be different
echo evaluations
it's not quite what it isn't the same it
isn't the same kind of thing
because um yeah okay sandra is pointing
out that the the uh
a skeleton object is of the form
it looks like something like this but i
don't think it's gonna look like that
let's see what billy comes up with
design wise
um all right can we go on
array we shape automatic dimension so we
had that very good discussion yesterday
about
broadcasting and other things which
hopefully we can bring to
one of these meetings soon right
um i think it was a very useful
discussion but complicated now how does
this relate to that
this is much smaller it's a small detail
it's about the alignment
of uh reshape layer and array reshape
so um so it has been pointed out that
the shape
layer can handle automatic and compute
the missing dimension
which i find useful i mean if you have
large objects you can say oh i want an
object of
these new dimensions compute the other
one so that they match
and so reshape our layer can do that but
array reshape cannot
okay so what you mean by that is i'm
trying to so this
array reshape is something that
essentially has um
uh it is doing like take list but it is
putting it in successive
levels yes i mean that seems highly
sensible to be able to have automatic
there
highly right it seems highly sensible
i don't have any problem with that um
there is one one detail which is a
shape supports padding and so by default
if you ask for more
something larger or something smaller it
will pad appropriately
so so what's the meaning of automatic
when it's going to pad it's the
no padding it's the it's the minimal
dimensions with no padding
or the minimal padding say
so i think should be no budding but just
wanted to yes i mean wait a minute
i believe it's no padding but but what
if you can't do it what if there's no
what if there's prime numbers and things
what happens if there's primes
do you understand my question oops
so you see there how the last submatrix
is a matrix of series
is padded
i see so if i did for example if i did
here
three times four but this thing was 31
then what the heck is that doing well
you ask for less you ask for something
in which the result is smaller so oh i
see i see i see i see i see so if i did
automatic there
and what's the relationship to partition
how does the ray reshape relate to
partition is it a deeper partition so to
speak
um i think it is
in a sense so it's a recursive partition
go ahead i think partition doesn't
specify
the final dimension it's just the blocks
you want
and it will break into those blocks
okay but so in the case where we said
three four or three comma
what am i doing three four
i'm now totally confused another three
three four three and you see how the
ended palette
with a few zeros how do i specify the
padding
the third document as an x at the end
i'd say okay so you're asking
if i said automatic for three
i think it would choose two because
three cannot
he would have too bad
this automatic thing is a little weird i
mean so so i could put any
automatic for any of those and if it is
a perfect
fit then no problem but if it has to
pad it would choose that number which
leads to the minimum
padding is that what you're saying or no
padding at all
so it's the smaller it's the largest
thing that can enclose
inside okay but but if it's the
automatic is not the last
argument that works but if it's the last
argument why wouldn't it just
always end up with singletons there
because it can always do
am i very confused
it would choose the the smallest number
that
um
no sorry the the largest number that
that
makes the whole thing that the whole
result not to have anybody
any valid results
but the fact that it's an intermediate
automatic
yes we can have only one automatic
okay but so it it takes the largest
number
for that position that leads to no
padding
but what if there is no no padding
solution
that doesn't drop data
you mean even one boot
look if the only solution is to put a
one there it's a total mess
but even that might not work because
then it still has to be a multiple
the total length still has to be
multiple of the last index
you know the last dimension length
so i think in general cases there will
always be a solution
it's just that it might be zero for
example if you start with range
of 13 and then
you have three four
yeah sorry a range of 11
and then three four comma automatic
this isn't implemented is it no okay but
this case even if it chooses one you
would be asking for something
of size 12 but you only have
11 elements so it would have to buy once
so in that case it will have to choose
zero and returns an
empty array
what an earth happened here it's
that's pretty lame
all right explain to me again what this
is going to return 3 4 automatic what's
it going to return in this case
in this case with the rule of no padding
then it will return an empty array a 3
times 4
times 0 dimensions so
what will it actually return um
do constant array of
zero comma three four zero
zero comma three four zero
that's what it'll return yes because in
this case
there is no solution with padding
without padding sorry
and with no padding this is the other
side but this is a very corner case i
mean
you know i'm good with doing this if it
just
generates an error message in the case
where there's a
where it doesn't fit where there isn't a
solution
okay so the zero case is good yeah
well i i think that that should error
out whenever
if there's a solution for automatic here
that it's just an integer and it fits
everything perfectly
in other words if this thing here
has a length which is the product of you
know
those things and an integer here then
it's great just do it
if it doesn't fit i think for now it
should error out
okay i was trying to have some sort of
up to situation
which it does its best well fine then
let
let people say up to there
if that's what you want to do then just
say up to whatever
i recommend just implementing the thing
with automatic with it erroring out
in the case where it doesn't make a
perfect you know an integer fit
and then um uh let's let's play with
that a bit
and see what happens maybe there's a way
to do up to but i think this is super
confusing
i think you're off by one and the thing
blows itself up i it seems wrong
um okay
all right should we move on here is
billy ready to tell us about more echo
evaluation or not yet ready
no okay all right let us know when
you're ready no problem
okay calendars
okay so i will explain a bit and then
nick will take over
um so we are by the way nick i do want
to just say
uh the things i sent you from uh
our outside enthusiast
um the um uh
uh you know please make sure we
understand how to
provide feedback there okay yeah
um
okay all right give us some introduction
here
yes so nick and i have been working with
an intern
on the extension of the calendar system
and
we have a now a large collection of new
calendars more than 40
from the four we had before and what we
want to discuss
we want to show you how how it works and
we would like to discuss the extension
of calendar data
which is the natural function to include
all these new calendars but it had a
a different slightly different design so
we have a calendar data
underscore new
so there are two different things to see
here the the the aspect of the new
calendars which follow your projections
so
it's a list of string comma parameters
rules
and and then the design of calendar
so nick can you explain uh first of all
do i i need to remind myself what
calendar data is right now i didn't even
know
so right now calendar data is set up
pretty exclusively around holiday
calendars
um so exchange calendars and different
national holidays
so as you can see the null argument case
basically lists
which countries there are that's pretty
lame yeah
it's something where i think you know
that function probably should have been
called
holiday calendar data or holiday
calendar lookup up
[Music]
what is holiday condo holiday calendar
is the option
for selecting holiday schedules so you
know in
if you're doing a fit of financial data
from the new york stock exchange
and you want to make sure that you're
not interpolating over holidays you need
to know what the new york stock exchange
holiday schedule looks like so just to
get a sense here i mean are you
suggesting that
i mean clearly in terms of compatibility
we can clearly
you know i mean are you suggesting that
this is holiday calendar this we change
this to basically holiday calendar data
and that this becomes i don't know
historical or i don't know
what what i mean okay
all right let's see what you're
proposing here and we because
yeah so basically what we'd like to be
able to do is to be able to
look up some data about these date
calendars
um and calendar data seems like the
natural
place that we would want to do that and
well i mean we could call it calendar
system data
or calendar type data um
i would say calendar system i think it's
better than i mean it's it's analogous
to geo is it analysis of geoprojection
data or
what is the thing which stores datums
you have to see data
but i think this is this is the
equivalent of geoprojection data so to
me calendar is equivalent of your
projection
okay so calendar system
seems i mean i i wouldn't have a problem
calling it calendar system
if if we're why not calendar data
well because we've already got something
else called calendar data but let's
let's cross that bridge in a minute
what a holocene halo scene which one is
it
on both sides okay
what the heck is an arithmetic calendar
system oh as opposed to an astronomical
calendar system
yes so we have a little blurb at the
beginning you know
most calendars are based at least
somewhat on an astronomical
system but the arithmetic ones use you
know fixed arithmetic formulas rather
than
looking at the position of the moon and
the position of the sun from a given
location
where the ones we call astronomical
calendars do some sort of astronomical
um okay so so the other ones just use
the year
basically they have fixed rules
yeah what they have done is to take the
the periodicity of the sun and the moon
and approximate it by some fixed rules
which of course get misaligned after
thousands of years yeah but who's
counting
i mean right i mean that's very good
yeah
pope gregory fixed all that at some
point
in the 1500s right yes but it will get
misaligned again in
like 10 thousand more years or four
thousand more years i think
it's very funny we have discovered that
newton created an uh a better one
is that right yes nito has his own
calendar that i didn't know
no i didn't know that either and it's
very funny it's it's uh
it's like the gregorian calendar but
instead of 400 years it's 500 years
and then every 5 000 years there is a
year with two
leap days and this is this
is perfect to i know hundred thousand
years or so instead of
a few thousand years oh well people
should have paid more attention to old
isaac
he was always complaining about that
from all accounts i think he was into
these non-commensurate things he
invented this non-commensurate weights
for british
uh british coins and things like this
huh
okay it's always interesting
yeah go ahead newton was responsible for
the mint in england in
1700 in the year 1700 which is the first
time that
the julian and the gregorian calendars
had to defer
so it was his decision what to do and i
guess he said
well if we are going to change this
let's do it correctly
but that but then then nobody did it
right but nobody did
no nobody paid attention to his calendar
i mean
and england eventually changed in 1752
not in 1700 wow
fascinating yeah well one always finds
these things like newton was also
involved in the first
math textbook for high school
at least you know first of a modern
times math textbook
again one doesn't know about these
things um
okay
all right so what's the question here so
so so
the end result here is so the first
thing we need to see
which is in the in the agenda notebook
is how we express
non-default parameters some of this is
crazy
location geoposition zero zero zero
that's crazy
if i might say so yeah that should it
should be all
or something well it should probably it
should be omitted for
calendars that don't actually the
gregorian calendar doesn't have a
location parameter so it
it shouldn't be there but for an
astronomical calendar
that has arrived but also it's a
geolocation right and
that's one thing okay next question is
what happens for a calendar on mars
i mean i hate to plan ahead but you know
what does happen
who is going to make that somebody
should do that
there is actually i mean there is there
are pages on martian time
for sure the so here we have to
distinguish
in the same way that ngo will
distinguish projection from datums here
we have to distinguish calendars from
time systems
and time system is the one that will
provide martian time
now martian time can be expressed in
other calendars
but wait a minute the martian year
i see martian time as in something based
on a point
on the martian surface with some number
of souls that's aligned to souls is that
right
right exactly but somebody can define
martian months and so on right
well um
we would have to look at the moons of
months perhaps
they're very small i'm not sure that's
done i i've never heard of martial
months but certainly of marching time
well somebody's going to need martial
months at some point
i have to say i'm adding this to my list
of student projects for next year's
summer school
it's for somebody to make up a martian
calendar it's a good thing to do
well um they will have two concepts of
months because they have two moons
two moons that's going to get funny
oh yeah great um
it's a bit like the imagine calendars in
which every day they they increased one
two numbers so the numbers were moving
simultaneously not
periodically once only
um
what about the moon the moon has no
meaningful
that's much crazier situation because
it's clearly it's months
and it's days that's totally crazy
um okay so let's come back to this all
right so what are we figuring out here
so i think our motivating factor is
we're adding a bunch of calendars
there's some information you want to
look up about them we need
some sort of data function to both list
what calendars are available
and what the default parameters are you
know for a lot of calendars you have
similar default parameters
most of the time they start at midnight
for any of the arithmetic calendars but
some
start at sunset or at sunrise or
noon the day before or the day after
and some calendars default to having a
year zero some default without it and
right now that detail we basically just
have to have a documentation note
and there's no way to control for it and
with the parameterized calendars you can
say i want a gregorian calendar that
does include year zero
or that starts at sunset instead of at
midnight
and you can basically okay so so let me
make a couple of suggestions so first of
all i don't know why this isn't an
association here
and i would strongly suggest that what
we do is we have
basic names like gregorian but that we
then have as an alternative to just
gregorian we have this be an association
where it says something like calendar
system arrow gregorian
year choice i don't know year origin
arrow whatever
blah blah blah blah blah that making
some sense
so in other words that instead of
instead of doing something like this
that we basically puff out
we say these are the you know the mayan
tolkien calendar
has some defaults but then if you want
to you can give
a more parametrized version of that
right
yeah and that's the the notion of how
we've extended the calendar framework in
general
is that you know if you want to do
conversion between a gregorian calendar
with your xero versus one without you
can basically specify
both of those you could do the same
thing
um with the sulkin calendar so i think
using an association probably
makes sense there too okay you can't
custom define your own calendar randomly
based on parameters
because no we're giving you particular
parameters
yeah in the same way that geoprojections
you can't arbitrarily specify
a new reference geoid or something like
that but you can change the centering or
something
how does that work for the geo
projections well we're doing that
it was a pre-association uh design right
and we might want to write it so
the idea is again we have mercator for
example which is
uh using the
default parameters and then you can
change the parameters
centering how do you change the
parameters you say
the first example for example you see
the the bomb projection
so that's a specification again of the
default
so that that reports the defaults you
can write you can copy that
change center into 40 20.
are these strings are these these
things we should change this to an
association
i think i think everything should be
supported
yeah i agree but but the output from
geoprojection data the default output
um
okay so this is a geogrid position
with that geoprojection
exactly with default parameters
now you can replace that bond in the
second argument with the output of the
of the first example and it will be the
same
the same numbers
right if you change now center into 40
20 it
will give you different numbers
right and that's its way of specifying
bond with center in 4020 right it
realized that's the only parameter you
changed
with respect to defaults so that's what
it keeps
although that means there's no canonical
geogrid position
object in general in other words putting
in what up well i guess it is canonical
if
it just includes whatever differs from
the from the um
uh you know from the defaults
okay okay that makes sense okay so let's
not compound them as
the the sort of the primitiveness of not
using associations here
seems to me all right so what you're
doing this is a direct copy of this
so this is saying so the location would
be omitted in this case or it would say
all
yeah it should what does location so
location hold on a second
location is for a for a
loony solar calendar or something
location i mean if you're
in mecca or not in mecca or something
that matters right
right it's the basically the the
reference point for any
solar lunar observation so the persian
calendar typically uses tehran as a
default
location for all measures but you could
have a variant that uses another place
in the persian empire or it could be on
the other
surface anywhere on the surface of the
globe
the right difference between the chinese
the japanese and the korean
lunar calendars is just what the
reference location is
by default i see
i see okay all right so let's walk
through this again so in general
then date object is going to have an
argument which specifies
or an option value that specifies which
of these things it's talking about is
that correct
yeah so calendar type already supports
the named calendars of gregorian which
have
default parameters assumed but you could
specify a calendar with non-default
parameters
i could say again using gregorian as an
example i want a gregorian calendar that
does include year zero
because our default doesn't okay so in
other words
okay so then then what does does date
object
auto canonicalize or does it sit it sits
in whatever
the calendar specification that's been
given here and how do you convert it do
you just say
you wrap it in a data object with a
different uh
with a different um setting for calendar
type
you can or you can use calendar convert
explicitly we'll take a data object with
account what is that new
uh note we introduced that in nine i
think
if you don't do a lot of conversions
between
different types uh
probably don't come across it as much
but yeah i say okay
both forms work so we both allow the
sort of
geoposition model of changing
datums directly within a wrapping object
or doing an explicit conversion
all right okay so what we've got here so
in a date object we can't use yet
the holiday can we use the you know
the the japanese stock markets holiday
calendar
or is that not do we specify that in the
date object or not
we don't because the a holiday calendar
is really defining
the criteria that define whether a day
is a holiday or not it doesn't change
the fundamental representation of the
date itself
you know okay so what then what then
gets the information that we're talking
about the japanese stock market calendar
or something
generally date range date
round day plus etc so what what
what is their do they have an option and
what's it called
so yeah they have a holiday calendar
option
and basically holiday calendar affects
what is and isn't a business day and
what
is and isn't a holiday those are two day
types
within our framework
there is some discussion in the agenda
at the end of the agenda
and you see the functions that have
adoption
okay calendar convert works with these
defining which day you're talking about
calendar stuff is that correct correct
and right now calendar data works with
holiday calendars
correct that's i think only they can the
concept
of calling calendar is incorrect
it's more like a holiday criteria
criterion
so i think the confusion is that
holidays are expressed in a given
calendar
but whether one day is a holiday or not
it's independent but what do people
call it in i mean in in the finance
world they call it a holiday calendar
don't they
yes but with the with with the sense of
collection of
holidays
but so what we've got is we've got these
two functions holiday calendar data
or calendar which is now calendar data
and we've got the holiday calendar
option for functions that have weekday
and things like this send them is that
right yep that's correct
okay
oh boy
and and we've also got okay so like that
stuff that george was looking at
that is um historical calendars
that was yet a different thing right
yeah that is that's related it has a
couple of related aspects
one is like the switch between calendars
so the switch from julian gregorion
right which we should know for a given i
mean honestly that could be in country
data
should certainly be in historical
country data it should probably be in
country data
i don't know whether that's a question
for alan whether that should be in
country data or historical country data
i mean we have that data within alpha
for sure
in the switch sweden's a particularly
complicated case because they switch
twice
they switch from julian to gregory and
back to julian back to gregorian
so there's nothing when did they do that
i don't remember the specific dates off
right so then basically what you're
telling me is
for a given country and i'm sure the
borders of those countries were
different and all kinds of weird stuff
like that
yeah and lots of parameters have changed
over time the notion of when the year
starts
you go far enough back it's generally
mid-march
and within march it moves around before
we sort of settled on january 1st being
the beginning of the year
there's a there's a lot of tendrils in
historical dates
um you know some of the things like
these parameters controlling for year
zero
are important because that
there is no universal standard for the
gregorian calendar handling year zero or
not
half of the standards have it half of
them don't because technically
it's only valid for years after 1582
but everyone right extrapolates
gregorian has a different issue
all right okay so first question is what
are we doing
i mean so the concept is
i mean one thing that's even more
confusing is holidays
you know when there are religious
holidays that are based on a lunar
calendar
how does that relate
so the holiday criteria are often
calendar specific so easter is really
hard to
express in terms of criteria on the
gregorian calendar
but it's really easy to express on the
ecclesiastical calendar
you know it's so many weeks yeah okay
relative to plan
um and so for a lot of our current
version of holiday calendar basically
has
schedules that are based on each
calendar and we'll say
for the u.s there are these holidays
that exist
using these gregorian date patterns
these ones exist using the
ecclesiastical
date patterns okay i understand
so all right so we've got
the storage of the holiday data for a
given country
is that static or does that have to be i
mean in general
is that like an entity property type
thing it is
it's currently not exposed through
entity value it's its own paclet
but it does periodically update you know
new holidays will get added for some
exchanges or the exchange will be closed
for some specific
reason what about two exchanges within a
country that have different holiday
choices
does that happen it does so if you look
at
if you do call that example there of
holiday calendar united states
there's a different schedule for
government bond nasdaq
nerc and new york stock exchange
okay all right okay all right so this is
just the wrong use for calendar nature i
mean we can grandfather it but it's the
wrong use
yeah and so we were thinking
does having a standalone holiday
calendar data
function make sense or should it i don't
just don't know yeah but i mean the
thing that you give it
is not united states it's i think what
it is it's an
entity it is a a holiday authority so to
speak
which might be nasdaq or something like
this right
right i mean i think that's ultimately
what it should be
be tied to now we can give people
convenience strings and so on to access
it but ultimately that's what it should
be
yeah and then then so that's a you know
a holiday
calendar type or something holiday
i mean i schedule entity or something
like that
your standard holiday schedule i don't
know whether there's there might be some
term for it in the the
iso standards world or something like
this let's look that up but i think
fundamentally there's an entity
and the property of that entity is its
holidays
um and and and that is going to have to
be parameterized because it's going to
be by year because somebody may have
added you know
i don't know i'm not not make let me not
make undue
you know in the us you know somebody
could decide that some
or in any country many countries will be
much worse than the us in this regard
that somebody you know the heroic day of
so and so so and so
well like columbus day in the us for
example you know what was a heroic day
for a while there's no longer a heroic
day or is a heroic day again
and so the holidays will clearly change
year to year
i mean when i lived in england it was
always entertaining because even the the
the um the daylight savings time stuff
jumped around depending on
political party and so on um
but so my point is that holiday calendar
data will have to also know the year
in general right
but i think what it needs is a criterion
and the criterion is a word of the year
it will say it's all the fourth of july
but in this year or starting this year
or except so what are you proposing
you're proposing that the functions that
manipulate
dates that care about whether something
is a holiday or not
i mean they know an absolute date so
they know it was the year 1752 or
something
right right but we are going to have
this new function called date select
which takes a period and then a
selection criteria and
and extracts the the sub
uh periods that obey that criteria
so so what i think
a holiday is here is it's just a
criterion
of selection not a calendar because for
example imagine that
you have the extinct calendar that nick
was talking about before
there may still be different churches
different religions that use the same
ecclesiastic calendar to define
different sets i think
of holidays right so the important thing
is the name of the
holiday set the holiday criterion
not the calendar itself
i understand um
well okay so what is this it's holiday
i mean it's partly a holiday authority
but it might be a holiday
holiday source holiday but but but what
we're trying to name here is two things
we're trying to name
the option a new name for what is now
the calendar type
option
when it is being used for that purpose
as opposed to
that what might arguably be called a
calendar system
which is what i claim calendar data
should be calendar system data
or maybe date system data i don't know
what is that does that make any sense
instead of calling calendar at all
or is it really always called calendar
i think for what we want the new
calendars are true calendars
the equivalent of your projections it's
the holiday calendars that
seem misnamed no no i agree i agree i
agree i agree so so i mean the new
calendars
well the question is do we really want
to call it calendar data or do we want
to call it is it a calendar or a
calendar system
i think it's a calendar everybody refers
to them as yeah the literature tends to
refer to it as a calendar
all right okay so then what we're
talking about is calendar so calendar
convert
is talking about this type of calendar
that we are now discussing right
so this is this is calendar in the sense
of
calendar system right
okay now the option is however
really so we've already got a holiday
calendar option
well so it probably why don't we just
call it holiday calendar data
i mean i understand that it's a that
it's a um
um i mean
in principle you could complain that
that's not a calendar it's really a
criterion for a holiday
but i think it's good enough to call it
a holiday calendar
and then what that takes is this is
crazy
in my opinion i think what we should do
here
i mean there we should just be able to
say nasdaq
can we do that right now for calendar
data
uh right now it doesn't accept it
because
there's the unfortunate precedent that
there's a bunch of
defaults associated with different
countries
i don't think any of the exchanges
should have overlap but
do you mean there is a nasdaq in
somewhere else no i don't think any of
the exchanges have duplicates but all of
the countries have a default that's
given which is duplicated but
it yeah i think in general
you should be able to provide nasdaq and
i like the idea of migrating away from
country names
to instead going to holiday calendar
sources or holidays well okay the
default
okay listen the default is
the country's the government calendar
right
right i mean there's also the
distinction like in the us between a
national holiday versus a federal
holiday
and gosh what is the difference between
those so generally a federal holiday
would be any time that the post office
is closed i see
where a national holiday generally has
official observation
i see so the the national one is the one
that we want to be the default
the federal one is just related to the
us government right that may be
and that's the thing we want to have in
there well and the other thing is u.s
states have their own holidays yep
yeah like massachusetts has one patriots
day
yeah um
so we can presumably balloon out a bunch
of extra holiday authorities or holiday
calendar sources
and populate those with holidays from
administrative divisions or countries or
exchanges right and the default then for
calendar data
would be to use given an administrative
division it will be
the the the not
the federal not the not the not the
state government
but the states you know like i think in
massachusetts there are holidays which
are um you know like the national
holidays they're recommended holidays
for organizations they don't happen to
necessarily coincide they're not the
the the you know the the the
local you know fish and wildlife office
or something
might take a different set of holidays
right
okay all right so fine so then calendar
data
becomes um and so this return from this
default case of calendar data
this would return this would disgorge
just like geoprojection data
if i say geoprojection data of mercator
that will disgorge that i see
i see that gives what you would feed in
as the fully qualified object
right to
it's a little bit of a weird form here
and i'm wondering whether we should
actually return something more like
in modern you know modern thing like
mercator arrow and association
what do you think
well any equivalent syntax is is fine i
mean this is just what
is there since version seven and we
didn't touch it in
version 10 when we started our our whole
of view
okay well we just need some consistency
but
i mean insofar as this is going to be
fed into other places we can have
anything we want to return but insofar
as this is directly used if it is
anywhere
that's a problem if we change the format
i'm sure some functions are used in this
output
it'll have to be updated
i mean it'd be nice to be able to just
get
this output um
different formats
um as a suggestion
of a person could be useful the
discussion on calendar data can somebody
make a note of that
on the live stream
thank you for the suggestion
um
okay look what i suggest
is that what is the second argument to
geoprojection data right now
the properties
okay that's fine
okay so the properties then become
are things like centering and so on
right exactly
okay fine so then what i suggest we do
is we make the default return
be a pure association
um you know whatever we call this
whatever you want to call this
projection type
arrow mercator and then all the rest of
it
then one of the properties becomes
something like classic or legacy or
traditional or something
to give this return result
um
then you know there's a question about
the discovery interface
for calendars and i think what we're
tending to do is to put in wdr
you know put in the data repository just
lists of everything we have
so that's well discoverable and so it
isn't i mean right now
this idea is in my opinion a little bit
crazy
i mean i guess we can support this i
just think it's a little bit it's fine
we can support it it's kind of a hack
but then these become not countries but
the names of all the different
um uh
well this will be completely different
this will be the names of of the
genuine calendars and holiday calendar
data
right would be essentially this but with
these things now turned into
the um holiday calendar entities which
would include things like nasdaq
and massachusetts state government or
whatever else
okay i guess i think that i think that's
cleaner and that keeps the language and
function names consistent across the
usage
fine okay all right so we've agreed on
that so then
holiday calendar arrow and then the name
of a holiday calendar can stay
in those functions yep okay
um all right so let's go back here and
just look a little bit at this
so i suggest that the default return
from calendar data
then becomes an association like i'm
suggesting for these other things
makes sense okay do you want it to be an
association
like the mercator then goes to value or
do we want an association that says
goes to gregorian and no no i'm
suggesting i'm suggesting this
yeah calendar type goes to girl guru and
blah blah blah that's what i think
okay now um
so i think that deals with that
and now okay we got a bunch of fun funky
calendars here so those calendars then
have options right
and then this would become the
association
if they are non-default cases if it is
just gregorian with its default
values it's just the string gregorian if
it's non-default it becomes the
association with all the non-default
things filled in
yeah right okay then um
and that option can stay as calendar
type
right right because it's consistent with
calendar convert and calendar data then
still fine okay then
uh okay so i want to put another
thing in here which is i think we should
be able to have
so where do we look up the uk 1700
what was its calendar in use how do we
look that up
so i mean let me give you a very
practical point
i mean in you know historical documents
around that period like newton's
birthday
okay is something in january 1642
and that was ns news style
in os old style it was december 25th
1641 i think okay
so in other words that is a common thing
to do for dates around that time in
historical documents is to write
old style or new style meaning julian or
gregorian
so we need some way to mirror that but
we also need some way by the time we're
at 1800 in the uk
we are definitively in gregorian
calendars
so i'm just saying we need some way to
represent all of that stuff
um so i think there is a natural way to
do that it would be
in historical country data we would use
data of england comma year
comma calendar
for what for i mean like the battle of
hastings or something
you know when was that i don't even know
what date that was but but
it shows i was not paying attention and
some um i don't think they ever
mentioned a date maybe it's not known
about the date
it must be known what the date was
because
yeah yeah um
okay in any case um so
but but that uh
let's see what we're just saying you
were saying that i think there are two
different questions here one
is the question of what's the calendar
that was being used in england at this
time
and the other one is give me the date of
the
battle of hastings in this calendar
okay fine but so the first question is
for a battle like that
okay let's find out what we actually say
it was
um uh
fascinating but now what actually is
that
right so that's that's assumed to be
right so most probably that's the right
day in the wrong calendar that would be
my guess
i talked to alan last week a bit about
some of this
historical data stuff and he's having
ben and a few people investigate and
make sure
that we're properly curating the
historical dates
with respect to the right calendar okay
but so this should have in it julian
calendar
it probably should yeah okay and so what
should happen is in the display here we
should know
i think for you know
gosh this is difficult because some
places only switched you know
like after 1900 like didn't russia only
switch after 1900
okay so in any case what i'm saying is
for some
some dates okay it will be good so this
in its raw date object should say
calendar type julian or whatever it is
right yeah and then in the display
form here i would argue that it should
give
like for example that day of the week is
going to be completely wrong if it's the
wrong calendar
right but the location doesn't really
matter so
if you know it's in the julian calendar
you know exactly which day it was
it may be that it happened in the in a
country in which they had already
changed
but the days were uniquely identified
yeah so long as it's not one of these
calendars that depends on astronomical
observations and things
well it's like projections if you don't
say anything else we are assuming the
defaults
if you wanted different defaults it was
your fault not to add them
yeah well fair enough okay but to one
point is that the actual curation
of see the problem is what happens if
you convert
from a date that was in julian calendar
and it referred to something in england
right
but then so now
this is like when we return units
different
in the us and in europe so this is the
same thing
somehow we have to know that for this
date
we should be returning julian or we
should repeat returning okay i
understand but if you were to convert it
to something which is
uh a lunar calendar for example or one
of these astronomical calendars
don't you have to know where the date
refers to in order to be able to do that
conversion
i guess you don't know i guess i guess
it's just tough luck it's what whatever
you're converting into is what you say
exactly okay fine
all right so yeah the answer to brian's
question date object is already has a
calendar type in it
as we see there so this should probably
say
paren julian calendar here this this
will be the curation of the battle of
hastings date
should say its dueling calendar and then
when you display it it should say paren
julian calendar
yeah exactly okay that's the correct way
to do it
okay an idea we have considered but we
haven't implemented yet
is to have a notion of calendar which is
mixed it's a calendar it's julian from
this day to that day
and from this day it is gregory and then
it will do the right thing depending on
the date you are working with
it's an idea that also happens with
projections and we don't have it either
they are called
interrupted projections and it you use
mercator in this area of the world
and born in this area of the world okay
i think that's a future
luxury item exactly um
okay uh
are there questions here about what's
our source for actual ultimate truth of
times
that's a complicated issue having to do
with leap seconds and all kinds of
things and we are coming to that very
soon
right that's not this version but the
next version we're planning to do all of
that utm
time stamping stuff is that right jose
yes
i mean it's um
uh
yeah there's a question of what happens
um
um
uh okay all right so let's just
all right what else do we have to figure
out here i think we're pretty close here
yeah i think that pretty much squares
away everything we're looking at
immediately here um
we may have some revisions to do on the
names of the parameters i don't know if
like start of date
or start of day in year zero or the
names we want to use but we those are
easy okay so just just i'm sorry just a
recap on the ones which
are uh local dependent
how is that going to work so in a date
object we will be storing i see we store
an association
and this association includes the
location that
says calendar type arrow association and
that association contains
the location right if you're using
something other than the defaults
there's
an implicit location for the
astronomical persian calendar that is
tehran but if you want to use a
different location
you just specify it as part of the
calendar type
okay and it'll be carried around inside
the data okay and then then
calendar convert if you were to give it
you know you could give it as a
different location
potentially and it would convert that
calendar yep
you could have every other parameter and
the calendar be the same but change the
location and it would change the numbers
associated with that date
because they would be shifted slightly
okay
hey question are we what is the way of
generating for example for
jewish calendar of generating things in
hebrew
right now we keep things in their
transliterated form
we are looking at potential ways of
having the date format
be something you can specify and say i
want this in hebrew
there are complications with hebrew and
arabic being right-to-left languages
potentially but
i'm just throwing up my hands there yes
okay
that's horrifying well i think
technically with japanese dates if
you're using a formal imperial calendar
they're supposed to be top to bottom but
it's pretty standard to go left to right
so writing scripts always end up with
complicated edge cases but
we do have curated forms both
transliterated and in the native scripts
for each um and so we just have to find
the right interface to switch between
those two
okay question um for some of these uh
okay historical calendars
um so if you say calendar type
arrow a country now we're not going to
be able to do anything with that are we
going to be able to do something with
that
because there is presumably an official
calendar for most countries
is that stored in country data
or does every country in the world now
have gregorian as the official calendar
i think saudi arabia was one of the last
ones to adopt it but there's some like
the icelandic calendar is still
used in iceland to some degree it uses
the gregorian year instead of the
traditional
norse year but all 200 000 people who
live there
yeah okay so i don't know it's more i'm
sure that's more of
i i don't remember i timed out in there
as a tourist i don't recall
seeing any particular i i would have
expected that that would be of high
tourist value a different calendar
but i don't i know in japan i think the
imperial calendar is still
technically the proper calendar so
uh you know this is currently heisei
year 16
and what so the the imperial calendar
has
a dynasty so basically the name of the
currently reigning emperor okay i was
going to ask about regnal dates
yeah so that's an issue for roman times
i think babylonian times as well what
are we doing with those
so we we can in principle have those
exist as calendars so the
you know the roman calendar itself also
can be used kind of as a
deep formatting element in terms of how
you
write on the julian or gregorian
calendar or in principle other calendars
but
we don't want every single roman emperor
as a as
a calendar type no but we could
potentially have a
a roman regnal calendar that says you
know this is
the 14th year of caesar's right
i see so in other words it'll be a
generic regnal calendar
in which one of the things instead of a
location it would be
who's the emperor type thing yeah and
that's typically how if you get a
passport in japan
the date will be written out as the nth
year of this emperor's
reign and that gets complicated because
it can switch mid-year the switch from
showa
heisei was on like january 3rd so there
are three days of one year that are in
one
imperial reign and the rest of the years
in another one
okay so but why don't we i mean look
since we are we
already have i mean for leader data
which is slowly making its way into the
language
out of just well from alpha we should
have all the information we need
to make regular calendars is that not
true
i haven't looked closely at leader data
but it it seems
in principle yeah we should you know in
terms of extrapolation the standard
thing is just to assume whoever is the
current leader
lives forever until you have to update
the pack
gosh that's a mess yeah right you know
they're typically used more historically
than they are for
something yeah i don't think it's really
the you know the ant fear of hammurabi
is probably not worth where i mean you
know we can say we're in the year
4 000 of hammurabi or something or
whatever that's correct
um the okay but anyway
why don't we just check that this design
does not break down sounds like it's
going to work for regular dates are
there any other weird types of
types of calendar systems the there are
some
headless calendars so like the mayan
sulkin
and um my hob calendar typically
run i think in 72-year cycles and then
traditionally they don't keep track of
what cycle number it is but for our
implementation
if you want to be able to convert back
and forth we have to keep that argument
that's what we do
i don't think we should worry about that
i think they just weren't thinking ahead
yeah um uh
just one second on the martian calendar
question of whether this completely
breaks down because
obviously the geo model we have a
concept of geo model
which can go you know which can include
mars
what do we do for this i guess we could
have a parameter
for right which is going to change the
year length and so on right
so i i think it's just one more time
system in the same way that we put
mars in the place of a datum and then
everything in geo works
the same thing will happen here with
time systems
so time systems will play the role of
datums in the same way that calendars
play the role of your projections
so here this this just works right if i
say mod
no no not with your model here it's not
an option
it's a it's an argument to this
so we say comma mars like that okay so
then if i say geo let's
um geographically do geographics with
some
range geodesk
of that comma 50 miles
is this going to show okay cool
um and presumably dualization also works
for that
geoelevation data also works for this
yes we do have
elevation data for mars right
okay um all right fine
so that so i mean we're probably not
going to worry about this somebody on
the live stream mentioned that there is
some
known proposed calendar for mars
um might be fun at least okay
um
okay somebody is commenting that they
write software for a scheduling system
well maybe it's time to use well from
engine to
to power all the horrors of of um of
converting calendars
um okay
all right i think we wrapped on this um
and i think did we have something from
uh billy here
on that earlier discussion about um the
design of these uh
um evaluation echo things
i did send an email yes okay great
and so we are we are done on the
calendar discussion for now is that
correct yes i think so
great um all right let me just
pull this over here
all right so this is your proposal for
i don't think that looks bad
i could think that could be a little bit
smooshed up although although maybe that
loses on exactly the thing i was
complaining about with the ins and outs
what's this
that's an ordinary echo i don't think
that should go purple i think it's fine
like this
if you're really mixing evaluation ones
with
with just regular echo ones let's not
change the color of echo
we've had that for a couple of versions
i think it's a nice color
okay um i think this looks good uh wait
wait
what did you do with these are you are
you recoloring the actual output
uh yes but um
that's an interesting idea but i don't
think we can we do that
i mean we could we could set a different
style for evaluation echo
output are we doing that for any of the
other echo stuff
no i don't think we should do that here
i don't think we should do that at all
yeah only the label should be colored
yeah i think the other boot
so we should check that that's not going
to look stupid with the with the output
i mean it is conceivable we could do it
use a different size for the output but
i don't think we should bother
there but the fact that the input and
the output has
have the same color one complaint we had
last week is that they looked similar
when there are
very many and so we decided to have
different colors
maybe we just use black for the
results but the befores we leave them
like this or gray no no wait wait it's
not obvious we want to change the
styling because that's a big complicated
cascading mess with different style
sheets and dark mode and who knows what
else
right so the question what we're we're
thinking is we leave
this we don't mess with this all we're
doing is the prompts
okay right so the only question is
whether the prompts i don't think
there's consistency to having
i i don't know i mean i think we should
try it like this
i agree that it's a little bit similar
the
output yeah i mean whether this is a
this is an easy case for in-n-out
because we've got
this whole cascade of of different
depths right
if we've just got in out in out etc they
may look very similar
what could we do there is there a way
that we could change
slightly the saturation of one of them
or something like this
like for instance the the input one
could be slightly lighter than the
output one
that makes sense billy and then the text
on the
right is text on the right is always
black always black okay
so we're only changing the prompts what
are we doing with the labels
which labels these ones here if we add a
label
argument so like scroll down yeah i
understand i understand
um the label should be in the same color
i think
okay but i think i think you should try
um
um
um yes okay so
i think that's what try slightly lighter
for the input
and this color for the output and labels
in the same colors matching the colors
of the um
of the whatever's by the way what does
it look like when you have a label
for echo evaluation you're going to have
two copies of that label right
or can you have a label different label
for the input and the output
you can do either okay fine
okay all right we should we should wrap
here um actually i'm going to answer one
other question from the live stream from
muhammad
asking about all from engines for
android i'm probably the only person in
this meeting who actually knows anything
about
that because it's a meeting about
completely different subject the the
answer is
that the actual engine the raw kernel
engine we actually have had available
for android for a long time
although it's something for developers
and it's not on the kind of consumer
uh list in terms of the
the well from the notebook player
that's available on ios it is not
available on android that was a huge
amount of work and it's not going to be
available on android anytime soon
um so that that's really an ios thing
it's really neat i
use it all the time you can get sent a
piece of email that has a notebook as an
attachment and you can open it and
interact with it on your phone
it's really nice but sadly that took
like seven years of development work
so it's not the kind of thing where we
can just flip it around and do it for
android it's very deeply
interwoven with the ui technology of
that particular
um uh
um system and uh in terms of in terms of
deployment
of wolfram engines that is something
that's possible on android and if
people are actually interested they
should contact our partnerships group
it's um um that's a different story
but that's not providing a a proper
notebook ui
in that system um all right that was a
utterly irrelevant we went from the
calendars of mars
to the android um uh
android deployment okay
good stuff very nice work by the way on
the calendars that's that's
um i look forward to to playing with
that some more
um and i mean how close are you to
really
like everything every calendar that
that's seriously been considered
i mean are we are we far away or are we
quite close
the codes are working for all of them
no i understand that but i mean if i if
i just ask
you know the french revolutionary
calendar do we have it
yep yep
okay what do you mean two versions they
tried it different weeks they
there's an astronomical version and an
arithmetic approximation okay
but so this is you think this is
throughout history this is basically all
serious calendars that have been used is
that true
not yet there's probably we've probably
another
20 or so that we have reasonable what
what what types of places are they from
um i mean there there are like whimsical
ones you know people have proposed like
stardate calendars from
okay that's amusing but that's not
that's not critical
but what about ones that are actually in
historical documents and so on
for example an issue here is that the
chinese calendar which will have one
version
has changed about 50 times in the last
3000 years
okay so there's documentation
about the other versions yes i'm where
yes some of them at least
well but i mean you know emperor so and
so so and so
in 500 bc or something
uh you know is it is it just knowing you
know somebody knows there was an edict
to change the calendar or is it actually
known what happened
and if there are no documents we don't
care in other words the case where it's
interesting
is where you know you're looking at a
historical document and has a date on it
what does the date mean
this is really complicated to do in full
so for example
there are details like when they started
the julian calendar
they got it wrong at the beginning and
for like 15 years they were having a
live year every three
and then they had to stop adding libyars
for a decade because they had made it
wrong at the beginning
i mean if we want to to consider all
these details
i have a book in my office which is just
about the calendars used
in england in the last 2000 years a full
book
dedicated to it with all the exceptions
just just for england
right okay all right so so i mean
it's amazing frozen history basically
which is quite complicated
all right so well something to look
forward to for the future but i mean i
think the main main issue is so you're
saying that a julian date
when was that for the time of julius
caesar or what did you say
yes so he got it wrong basically no he
got it right but implementers
misunderstood the problem is that the
romans didn't have a zero
and so their accounting system was very
complicated
oh that's fascinating yes and i mean
the roman counting is for example days
to the calendars and the days of the
calendars they call this the
so the day before the calendars they
called it the second day to calendars
weird it's very weird because for them
what we would call the day zero
for them it was the day one
so yeah so that there of course they had
a
system which is was very prone to errors
by one
huh fascinating okay is it no one i mean
i just as a
history trivia question i mean is it
known like you know is there a
an extent you know proclamation from
julius caesar about what the calendar
should be
that was then misimplemented or is it
not um
uh is that it's not documented i mean
it's augmented that
they had to do this i mean yeah i think
it was for
the first three times they did it every
three years and then they realized they
were doing it wrong they had to stop for
like
seven years without any
lip day or something like that this is
written in various places
right fascinating okay well all right
well so
we are just doing the first cut here
which is going to get the 99 percent
uh or much more than that case and
something for the future to deal with
all of the weird
historical corner cases all right sounds
good
okay great um yeah i'm somebody is
commenting
truth teller is commenting on her get an
intern to translate that book into code
yes indeed
exactly what i was thinking um
and uh maybe george was looking at
some of these things uh uh as a hobbyist
would be interested in doing that
perhaps we should suggest that to him
okay anyway that's um all right
thanks a lot guys see you all soon
thanks folks on the livestream
great comments